νία οι επιχειρηματίες οι επιχερίς που έρχονται πότ εξωριγό που εργοδοτούν και κόσμο στην κύπρον
και τα λιπά και τα λοιπά άρά αυτός σημαίνει επικεντρόνουμε στον πολίτη και στόφελο τουπολύαυτό
είναι αντιπολευσει ενείκαι οποίάμε πίσω από οποια και δίπο έκλειστην πόρτα ανκύπαμε τους θα αυτό
θελα συγκυβέρνεις και πάμε κάποιου κύριε ξέρεις τα μέαμακάουμεντούτον τούτν τοται στις προτάσεις μας που
σουφέρνω θα πάει πολύ καλύτερα κυρέρνηση όχι δημόσια στο δημόσιο διάλογο καταθέτουμε τη διαφωνία μας
το πράγμα πυ πρέπει να καταθέσουμε αυτό να το κομμάτι της κριτικής και καταθέτουμ τινή
διανώρατης προτάσεις μας και αυτό ίνα το κομμάτι της παραγωγής πολιτικής θελά θελω τήσω θέλα
μο πείς ν πέντε πράματα που διαφωνί ο δημοκατικός της ναγερμοσμε εν κυβέρνηση και γι
αυτό να τιπολύτρες ναι περίμενες θα σου πω εκατόν ίκωση να σου ποέκαοίκωση πράματα που
προτείνουμε ότι πρέναγίνουν τσ να σου πω και πέτε που διαφωνεί αλλάσου πε κι κατοενκωση
γιατί αναφερνωτων νούμερο διότι ήθελα τελειώσω το κομμάτι πουτεετε μελέτιόχι όχι χι ήθελα τελειώσω το
κομμτι πουμε εξεκίνησε με το τι κάμιο συμπονερο κι μέ που πιστεύουμε και όπως ενοργανωμένω
από εμάστοσυμλιαεπειδή το ερωτί μας σου είχεν μιαοιπόνιγιατί το κάνετα αλλώσώμα λοιπόν το συμβολείον έσι
πένμαρ τα οποία θεσάνει μόνοι μας τα οποία πεανξμαρξα έχουν να γάμου με την πιοπιότηταν
ψε έναν επίπεδο ρα εμείς βγαίνυμε με προτάσεις μπορεί κάποια σχόλεια να ένα νλεπτομέρίας αλλά
βγαίνουμε με προτάσεις ολοκληρωμένες ολιστικής επίλησης ενός θέματος όπως παραδεήματος χάρι αυτό που σου είπα
πρηγουμένος ι όπως πααδημός χάρι πολύ σύντομα που θα βο